in a relationship you trust the other
and trust and Truth have the same origin
so I believe that whatever it is that we
know and experience ultimately comes out
of relationships and of course in the
Christian religion but also in other
religions the ground of being whatever
word one uses to describe that is love
and love is nothing except a
[Music]
relation
[Applause]
but I think I'm going to be the one that
kicks off so to
speak um first of all it's um a great
honor and pleasure to be able to have
this conversation R we've talked in
public before and in private but it's
always an honor and I think to a large
extent we we have um fairly similar
visions of the cosmos I I believe
um although we do maybe have points of
difference but what I wanted to say
because I think one of the the issues
we're asking about is the nature of
reality and so we've got less than half
an hour to get there but one of the
important points about it is that it has
always seemed to me since childhood and
certainly since my teens that the world
was rather different from the one that
is often explained in the modern idiom
which is of a world which is largely
sort of passively there and not
responsive to us that um opposites um
get as far away from one another as
possible whereas I believe they tend to
go inside um that context makes a huge
difference and that things are connected
one with another and the process of the
intellect is to divide them up that
dividing up is very important of course
but it's only a preparatory phase to
reconnecting something that is now more
complex and that I think is the bit that
we've lost sight of so in the Realms of
epistemology as I've laid out in the
second part of my uh latest book the
matter with things I I think there are
different ways in which we can get at
reality and they do involve science and
they do involve reason I'm passionate
about both of them but neither of those
will take us all the way by any means we
also need the capacity for intuition and
Imagination which teaches other things
that may be very true but difficult to
articulate in the terms or reach in
terms of um science and reason I mean a
good example is music something that has
um made my life as as happy as it is and
as fulfilled as it is and yet it is not
either Encompass by reason or by science
neither can really explain why Mozart G
quintet is such a profound
experience and starting from there just
getting onto the whole business of of
consciousness you know what is
consciousness and the idea that
everything can be reduced to Mere matter
that is if you believe matter is mere at
all which I don't um then you know um
you're missing an enormous amount in
life and I think the sense of something
beyond that is connected to us in which
we all C here which has
um um a a a
um an existence that that suggests
something rich and complex and that we
have intuitions of and are drawn towards
but can never fully grasp I think that
is where I would situate my my beliefs
about the place of the Sacred at any
rate in the idea of the cosmos as a
whole do you have any Reflections on
that
raren first of all um to say that I'm
very impressed you've managed to reduce
those two two enormous volumes for the
last 5 minutes um but that's not an
excuse for not reading the two large
volumes I I hasten to add a couple of
things which which have always struck me
about your work and which struck me in
the way You' presented it now which I
think are are key in pushing back at
some of the myths that hold us captive
in our contemporary culture first is
what you said about mere
matter we think there's a nice simple
opposition between materialism and
something else which is softer and
wooer and that means we buy into a
particular mythology about what matter
is we think matter is little lumps of
hard stuff yeah it exists in small
associations and big associations but
basically it's little lumps of hard
stuff what if we reset our imagination
where matter is concerned and think
about matter in terms of communication
frequency see energy in different
concentrations which is you know what
any self-respecting physicist will tell
you what if you start there it all looks
a bit different then and that leads on
to the second thing we've bought into a
picture of
knowledge which is essentially about
something in here looking out there
labeling categorizing and so forth
sitting still while we take a rather
slow exposure photograph of it as if
we're saying to the world around look
don't do anything just hang on while I
Fix
You Again what if the process of
knowledge is a matter of attuning to
energy communication that is coming to
us what if the form we in it is active
not just passive exactly and then I
suppose that really leads on to the the
third crucial element in what you're
sharing here which is that
that our characteristic position in the
universe as human
subjects is neither that of a sort of
mindless instrument of impersonal forces
nor the possession of a Godlike other
who has somehow parachuted into this
world
of little lumps of stuff our position is
that of someone trying to catch the
continuities trying to go with the flow
quite literally to make something of the
patterns of energy that are
communicating to us and part of that and
this is a key to the the sort of
granular work that you set out
especially in volume one of the two
books part of this is the recognition
that our brains are so
constituted
that it's not a matter of hard and soft
bits of knowledge but granular and
integrative kinds of knowledge if you're
capable of recognizing eyes noses and
mouths but have no idea what a face is
then there's something a bit wrong in
how you're relating and I'd love to hear
you say more about the the actual um
experimental evidence from the
neurological world that that helps fix
that those are the things which I I've
really taken us the take- home messages
from from the books yes thank you and I
probably won't because of time go into
the detail of the neurology but but
thank you for that recognition that that
that there is something there that I
think is important about two entirely
different ways of attending to the world
the prime difference between the
hemispheres is the kind of attention
they pay and I'm not going to take up a
lot of time on the hemisphere hypothesis
but what is important is that the left
hemisphere um sees these fixed things
that the camera was photographing as you
refer to so granular atomistic isolated
decontextualized abstracted fixed
whereas the right hemisphere sees that
in reality everything is connected
ultimately to everything else that it's
never completely fixed or known or
certain is knowable and we can have
greater degrees of certainty and truth
about it but it is not a final thing
that exists out there it is comes from a
relationship and this is the really key
thing I argue in the matter of things
that relationships are what the universe
is made of and that the relata the
things that are related emerge
secondarily from the web of
relationships I know that sounds
paradoxical but we Haven time to to to
go into that perhaps too much but the
point there is that things only become
what they are those things we think we
see because of where they're situated in
relation to everything else and the full
context in which they inhere and so that
perception changes the way we think of
knowledge it's not that there's stuff
out there that we can more Faithfully or
other otherwise record simply passively
it's something about if we really want
to know it we have to enter into a
relationship with
it and that means that something of us
goes into the experience of whatever it
is we experience no surprises in that
but it does not um emphatically insist
does not lead anywhere near a sort of
postmodern belief that we all just make
it up I I resist that with every fiber
of my being I think instead we have a
task a duty which is to follow
truthfully our intuitions where they
where they seem to be testable and true
in the experience of life and that there
is a truth but it is something that we
approach in a spirit of approximation
and and Trust in a relationship you
trust the other and trust and Truth have
the same origin so I believe that
whatever whatever it is that we know and
experience ultimately comes out of
relationships and of course in the
Christian religion but also in other
religions the ground of being whatever
word one uses to describe that is love
and love is nothing except a
relation and the way you put it there
reminds me of um the way in which
somebody like St Austin um talks about
knowledge itself we don't know unless we
love and doesn't by that mean we know
what we feel warmly about he means
simply that we have an investment in our
knowing this is about me and how I'm
going to be and how I'm going to receive
and give and when I'm in that kind of
relationship truth
actually impresses upon me I am in an
adequate or appropriate relationship
with what is coming to me and that's
truthfulness but precisely because it's
relational it's also time based you
can't freeze it you can't say well
that's that's it and that's all that
there ever will be to say and the other
dimension which I think comes through
very powerfully in your book in the
matter with things is the role of time
yes and the way in which um certain
kinds of dysfunction of the brain
manifest themselves as an inability to
cope with time sequencing and an
inability to see oneself as a Time bound
subject now that to me as both as coming
at it from a philosophical point of view
and coming at it from a a religious and
Theological point of view makes absolute
sense we are of our very nature time
taking beings growth is part of what we
are and if your ideal of knowledge is a
set of again Frozen photographs which
will be the same yesterday today and
tomorrow to use the theological phrase
then there's something again you've
really missed there but I want to come
back if I may into the the word
intuition yes you used I would Hazard a
guess that for a lot of people in an
audience like this the word intuition
has a very slightly loose feeling yes oh
I've got an intuition that that's the
case yes um but I think you're saying
something rather stronger than that
aren't you that there's yes there's a a
cohesive connection making capacity that
is just inbuilt in our mental process
which name it Intuition or whatever but
it's it's stronger than
a vague feeling isn't it yes I
intuitions can deceive us there's no
question about that and that's a point
of view that's put about and makes a lot
of money for bands of psychologists who
go into organizations all around the
world and say never trust your
intuitions however this is very foolish
advice and what we need to do is not
always trust but certainly not never to
trust but to pay adequate respect to our
intuitions the same is true of read
reason and science they can lead us to
mistaken places even reason can believe
me and so so I'm a great believer in
science and reason but they are not able
to tell the full story and intuition can
tell us enormous amounts and when you
have to collapse an intuition which is
often implicit into an expression in
language it becomes single explicit and
defined by language
whereas when it remains at an intuitive
level as many as 12 or 15 different
strands of knowledge and experience are
being brought together and weighed
together as a result of that a a jurist
in other words an academic um specialist
in the law in Germany the head of one of
the max plank institutes say says that
in every organization people should be
encouraged as much as possible to
understand their intuitions use their
intuitions and of course examine their
intuitions I was thinking there of um
something i' I've quoted more than once
in recent months and that is uh Phil
Whitaker writing in the new Statesman a
couple of years ago about um online
diagnostic tools in medicine yes and the
strength and the weakness yeah because
the weakness is that there will always
be in a physician's diagnosis elements
that do not yield readily to precise
formulation but without which you will
get things disastrously wrong in your
perception of what's there because the
online tools can only give you
information in response to certain
questions and those will be the
questions you're aware of but if you're
a good physici you will know in the
diagnostic process that there are things
you picking up which you don't know
you're picking up and that those will be
feeding in somewhere to our overall
response and I think it's that that
holistic sense and the sense of what
you're not actually bringing to the
Forefront of your mind that is important
it's not flabby it's not loose and
depressionism tools can be trained
obviously on masses and masses of expert
knowledge and then we think that they're
doing what the expert does and sometimes
they can be very helpful because they
can work faster um than the human mind
often works but they can be disastrously
wrong because everything this is a
simple point but a very important one
everything depends on its context and
the context of symptoms is a whole
person a life and all sorts of
circumstances that are going on before
and after the consultation and around it
so you always dealing again in a
relationship and what an AI tool doesn't
give us the option of is a relationship
it may simulate dangerously one and and
lead to a great deal of of of of um
untruth and suffering but it is that
relationship that matters and and you
know you were quoting Augustine and of
course there are others like Pascal who
learns a lot from Augustine who said
that first you must love something if
you are to understand it but of course
people would say but you can only love
it when you understand it and there's
some truth in what I'm getting at there
is a circular process or a recurrent
reverberative process so you you commit
yourself partially to something and you
see what happens and what happens guides
your response and its response and you
won't find this by sitting calmly
reading a book you have to be immersed
in the living process it's like trying
to learn to swim by sitting on the bank
of a river with a book and saying yes I
think I know now how to swim actually
have to get into the water to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit I a.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas